ce matin ces ateliers post-it au modem
les militants essaient d'élaborer le
programme du parti pour les prochaines
élections
si tu aimes qui correspondent aux
compétences des régions leur sont
proposés à eux d'exprimer leurs idées
sur des post-it
ce système est inspiré du monde
associatif aujourd'hui on n'est plus du
tout sûr du vertical on est sur lorenzi
l'horizontale les idées doivent
foisonner donc on a des tas de gens qui
sont déplacés de toute la région voulait
faire foisonner est prouvé que si chacun
apporte son idée on a des choses qui
sont très riches et que ce qu'on fait là
en interne c'est le modèle qu'on doit
porter au sein de la société
les idées sont nombreuses il faut donc
choisir deuxième phase de l'atelier
faire le tri parmi toutes ces
propositions votées par pavés et après
tout ce qui a été mis dans les pavés
sera réutilisé et sera approfondie et
certaines idées viendront enrichir le
programme de patrick mignola le candidat
modem pour les régionales investi jeudi
dernier il a fait à vaulx en velin sa
première sortie officielle
c'est aujourd'hui qu'on va commencer à
travailler à bâtir ensemble un projet je
crois que cette région auvergne
rhône-alpes a besoin d'un projet qui lui
ressemble
chaque parti politique essaie de fourbir
ses armes ici ou là multiplie les
déclarations nous notre boulot savez de
travailler sur le fond et de bâtir un
projet qui soit au plus proche des
réalités de la société civile de cette
région aux élections régionales les 6 et
13 décembre
les militants verrons si leurs idées
auront convaincu les électeurs de la
grande région envers nouveaux membres